how's it going bros my name is welcome
to another video
yeah today we're going to play some
simulator games
i made my research i collected some of
the very best
simulator on the market and we're going
to start with
superhero simulator
okay so this is how it works huh so i
can
fly i think how do i go forward there
must be some way to kind of
the life of a superhero it sure is hard
now let's go rescue some people oh come
on
damn it my ass don't you just hate it
when your ass gets stuck
in buildings it's the worst i think we
broke it
great all right let's go to the beach i
guess whoever made this game was like
you know what i'm gonna make the best
game
in the entire world and then he failed
miserably
there's no other people in this game so
i don't really see a point in
damn it where did my chair go where did
it go
what is this [ __ ] can i swim at least
there's some people there
damn it what happened all right maybe we
can fly there
i hear music hey buddy how you doing my
my black brother is that racist no i'm
superman i can't be
there we go you're hispanic that was
racist damn it
hey man watch me dance brother i
suck this [ __ ] okay
um i
i'm speechless i don't know what to say
about this
[ __ ] all right let's play some soccer
football
there we go let's see if i can score the
ball
that is one ugly football i gotta say
this is me practically doing sports like
i'm not
[Music]
there we go we i think we did it
yes score the ball oh
this could be it damn it damn it
um i think they titled this game wrong i
think the proper title is
satan's simulator i can't believe i'm
actually playing this game like it's
i'm amazed that i'm spending time in
this game okay i hear mute stock music
that means something great is about to
happen hey buddy how you doing man
hey man you want to dance i'll teach you
my dance moves
scissor me man come on assistant me bruh
that's right bruh
oh yeah that feels good disney bruh
okay i know you've been talking about
fixing uranus but that's too far
man i'm out of here nope
all right now i know what you thinking
my hair is beautiful
uh i i mean i know what you're thinking
there's no way in hell we can beat that
game there's no way in hell we can be
attacking
but yeah you're wrong we have boob
simulator here
that is one i don't know what that is i
don't
know if i want to know what that is
sexism in video games huh that's what
you thought
how can i adjust these are small size
breasts
medium-sized breasts that is one
big tit and then up to make it
larger nice so that's how it works
very educational here today bros oh god
that's
that's not very attractive it looks like
a water balloon pretty much
then i can make it softer let's make it
really soft
oh god that makes it saggy oh no that's
a sad
that's a sad kitty no one likes a sad td
hey titty come back
come back kitty that's right titty
that's that's a good titty
and then make it really hard like a like
a really
fake titty good old fake kitty
what am i doing with my life so i can
move the netball but i don't see the
nipple at all
that's the titty i was looking for look
it's shaking even are you nervous titty
why are you so nervous come down it's
okay
it's okay you calm down teddy calm down
teddy i need you to relax all right
what is it what what's doing this why
are you so [ __ ] excited calm down
please
it's a little zit kids don't make fun of
girls with small tits
i'm just saying all right might as well
suck on them
12 year old boy's dead i think this tit
has a life of its own
i'm surprised i haven't popped yet so
i'm really curious who made this game
and why
teddy wants to go to space titty gonna
pop will kitty pop
that is nasty i feel like my life has
become better
i don't know about you bros wait what
there's a falcon lover simulator
what who did this and why
where's the [ __ ] noscopes then what
does this baby have to do
i got no scope really
i got no scope into playing white fields
of africa
this is so bad but it's still like damn
it i keep getting no scoped
next up lsd simulator concentrate the
mind on the present
okay even if
[Music]
oh god take me away from here
stab hansel why did you have to eat the
chicken
damn racist chicken pewdiepie kissing
simulator one day
jesus one day pewdiepie asked maya to go
on a date with him or slash her and not
edgar because he's not gay
[Music]
how do you know let's play
there we are i like my uh business
it's very nice nice choice and put them
i like this
square kind of face that i have and i
like how maya doesn't have a body at all
very interesting just some paint
and some music and you got yourself a
kissing simulator alright so what a
thought the only thing worse than
simulator games is apparently my games
that's great
all right what do we got this setup
simulator the game is not installed
running installer would be a great idea
all right well where is it
potato salad recipe i looked everywhere
for this
credit card secret number that damn it
all right
don't look at my documents please it
detected a virus
come on you got a virus your computer
will die a terrible pain
i'll better get pong well [ __ ] you
like you know how to use that shut up i
did not remember my computer being this
sassy all right antivirus run a scan
that's too many times it's faster
this is going to take some time why
don't you play pog all right fine
playing most awesome first game ever
damn it damn it this is anything kill it
now
you may want to use command input to
install this game
all right d do
do i want do do what do
[Music]
d duty do delete
oh okay oh my god i'm such a hacker
we'll see who is the boss now
how did you how you did this is unknown
well i did it i installed fire exit now
play it low better you could be
damn it ah come on
you're the worst computer ever
all right well that was that one
all right for this evening my bros and
me ladies send
me shady haiti katy perry's
this is kind of an offensive title this
probably goes in the
in the bank with games you probably
shouldn't
play pewds don't play it pale shut up
there they are there's the president
there's
but a lot of people here uh there's that
books i want bugs
no one seems to care all right here we
go we're just lining up the shot
ready any second now
you can't tell me what [ __ ] oh double
kill double kill
double kill double kill there we go
jfk still doesn't give a single [ __ ] it
would appear that
no one gives a single [ __ ]
maybe he just really had to poop his
pants no one really knows
all we know is oh god what is that face
go back
why is everyone so gang god damn
attractive can we talk about that
how do they make everyone got a face i'm
gonna have nightmares
what was that
look at that he doesn't give a single
[ __ ]
no one cares they should rename this
game no one cares
see now you care stop rubbing your
nipples it's not gonna change anything
what are they doing that guy is just
like nope
[ __ ] this i'm out of here if you wanna
be
happy for the rest of your life never
make a pretty woman your wife
mistaken from my personal point of view
get another girl to marry you all right
so that's a weird ass [ __ ] game let's
just agree on that
look how dramatic my face is never mind
then all right chris i hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did
hit that like button and as always thank
you for being a bro and hit subscribe
and do whatever the [ __ ] you want just
watching my videos that's enough for me
stay awesome brass